hello i am in texas which means
that i am in texas and i am in texas
because i am recording
i'm filming when you're filming a bigger
project
you say you're filming something i'm
recording a video right now that you're
seeing
but i'm filming the sequel to a heist
with markiplier which should be very fun
and i can't wait for you to see but
you're gonna have to wait and meanwhile
i decided that the first video that i
was going to record while i was in texas
was going to be power wash simulator
and i'm going to admit i was playing it
a little bit by myself
i was cleaning the fire station and i
did it by myself
and i was having a good time but i
decided that i was going to finish it
with you
and it's not just because i didn't get
to finish it before i left for texas and
therefore it's a little left done and it
was bothering me the entire time that i
was traveling over to texas
because i didn't get to finish it so now
i'm going to finish it
for you also um it has been brought to
my attention
that there's a crucial feature in this
game
that i did not know about which
fundamentally changes the entire
experience
um you can rotate it
so um
i know it probably seems obvious to all
of you
who have like context clues and the
ability to read
and the ability to process instructions
that are given to you every single
loading stream that you go to
and i know you guys have been shouting
at me that i should
uh rotate it
and you're absolutely right like you're
completely justified in your rage
even the developers of the game have
probably
added in some additional information to
say hey
idiot you idiot there the guy who used
to have red hair
the guy who went to texas to film a
project you can rotate the thing you
dumb dumb like i'm pretty sure they
added something in like that
for me specifically all of my own fault
and i will blame no one else because i
will not
taint this pure game which is purely
enjoyable
and purely enjoyment with lies
and i will not do that i can't
absolutely promise that last detail
there
but i will do my best um as you can see
uh let me just showcase you the whole
i am the climbing mechanic still not
exactly good it's not what i would call
good
so i was i was mopping up this fire
station what i did before is i cleaned
up that fire tower first and then i went
over here and started cleaning up the
building
um really been kind of procedural about
this uh it's been very satisfying
and uh for the most part like you guys
will see
everything that i did in the time lapse
once that's done
i don't think there's anything here that
needs to be there i'm 95
of the way there so i'm pretty sure that
i'm gonna blast through this in no time
well there doesn't seem to be anything
here huh
aha i see you
okay well i'm gonna need the i'm gonna
need the big thing come here you
i summon thee so this is a useful big
ladder that i would have liked to know
about before and i probably would have
known about
before but you know it was in that other
level and i was like why is this thing
in my way
why is this big thing getting in the way
of me
cleaning i don't know look how useful
rotation is
god panning left to right is way better
than the oh that i was doing before
but it is much better and and before
even i was like man it sure would be
nice if i could do a sweeping motion
boy wouldn't that be some too bad
power washing technology isn't there yet
maybe one of my future generations might
be able to enjoy it
but not i i said with pure idiotic
confidence
this firehouse has also been very
forgiving in terms of like missing
uh spots here and there but man has it
been a nice one this one's treated me
right oh and lixian don't even worry
about cutting out too much of this you
can
really leave in quite a bit you know
even slow down some of the time lapses i
know these are notes that i could have
given to you at any point
in the editing process and i didn't
that's because i am a bad youtuber who
does not communicate well to their
editors and i will try better in the
future and i really appreciate
everything that you
rachel and marcus do
but if you could make it a little better
that'd be great thank you oh
what happened to you all right let me
just plop this i can definitely fix this
see look at this sweepage you just kind
of sweep you know
look at this turning angling
dangling the future is a wonderful place
everyone's always doom and gloom about
the future but hey
look at this this
is a slice of some special
[Music]
oh i wasn't even really done with that
but whatever if you're gonna be nice to
me i'm not gonna question it
i am gonna look side long at it though
ain't this grand look at that i know i
probably missed some small
obscure details somewhere that i'm gonna
have to go back and fix
but for now i'm almost done with these
so i can
rest assured that my efforts are not i
see you
i see you there
oh look at that the to-do list
oh wow
that's incredible that is incredible i
know what i need to do
i know what i must do but i don't know
if i have the will to do it
i do actually i incredibly have the will
i'm just
stunning oh look at that look at that
wall base well i don't know where that
would be wall base here we go
wall base wall base
wall this wall base
ah wall base i did not get this okay
and then drill tower ledge which i think
is on the tippy-toppy of this
tower and you you you
you oh i found you
ah you dirty [ __ ] how could you be so
disgustingly dirty
i am offended i'm offended for you and i
am offended
hey fa any chance you could come hose
down our spare truck the mayor's running
us ragged over here
okay wow look at that
see i got the tower first and then just
i started like wrapping around the
building just in sweeps
oh that is a that is a
that's a that is a
so i learned that i could rotate
the hose live my embarrassment was
broadcast to the members of this channel
and i feel very bad about myself and it
i believe that the one that i did for
them was
the forest cottage so i'll play that
that time lapse for you that's what i
did there
the roof was a pain the roof was a gosh
darn pain it was
unforgiving and the slopes were just
impossible to walk on
it's not like i had the big scaffolding
either but it was very fun and very
satisfying i did like it but there were
some details in there that made it kind
of annoying
um other than that oh
wow hey look at that i've got a penny
farthing came a cropper on the old
buy cycle seems an element of rust may
have crept in and seized up the ready
stop blocks
give the old boy a quick swish and
there's a shiny through penny
bit in it for you who are you anyway
i'll watch it
watch it look at r rotate or refill who
would have known
no one okay well this is a nice little
thing uh this is gonna need some loving
attention to detail
uh so i'll try to do a manual job about
this because otherwise it's going to be
over in two seconds
i'm gonna i've kind of worked out a
strategy that like i want to make sure
that i get the details oh also you can
go prone now
sniper style so that way you uh if i get
the small details first then i don't
have to worry about them
and i can kind of like isolate what i'm
doing and definitely be like yeah this
isn't clean or yeah this is clean
or yeah i'm not clean or yeah
i'm clean there's a joke about being
dirty in here but i don't want to
gunk up this whole episode with that and
this
rather nice series with my stupid
asinine
crude humor penis ass butthole balls
butthole [ __ ] pee-hole pee-pee pants
i'm a mature adult come on that middle
thing is not
oh it's considering the whole wheel oh
interesting
maybe it wasn't any kind of nooks and or
crannies in this thing
not really a lot of uh of small bits and
bobs to the penny farthing is there
not even a gear box
[Music]
now that's looking good how did you even
step on this who designed this i mean
of of course mr penny farthing i'm i'm
guessing but
or miss penny farthing who am i to say
but also it's stupid well i better look
from the top because it's so
gosh darn tall
[Music]
i'm probably spending way longer than
this would ever name oh three to do
all right i guess i'm almost done i'm
just slow
i didn't even need the hyper blaster you
know
probably would have been fine without it
but whatever i guess
this job's over and i won't be satisfied
anymore
[Music]
and the frame bam what a tremendous job
he's come out an absolute dream
if he didn't ride so beautifully i'd
flog him to a museum
i don't know what that means algernon
evans
algernon algernon algernon
algernon algernon yeah i spent a long
time on those pedals
i spent way too long on the details of
this it did not need
as much you think it's jealous of that
other bike in the background
not after it get clean though that is a
good looking bike
okay grandpa miller grandpa oh god this
is the
house with the dead people there oh i
didn't even read what it said
how am i gonna know the lore okay hello
doc i hope you're as good with
hello doc i hope you're as good with
cars as you are with houses cause i've
got my own wagon out of the garage and
it's nuttier than a dog beetle's
christmas list
it still turns over fine but i'm not
taking the lawyers out for a sprinkle
it's just
claiming as she is thanks leonard
if afterwards you can hit her with the
power of us that'd be great
lexian make that more satisfying because
i know people are watching this for a
little bit of elegance to it so
just do it you can put like some smooth
jazz under whatever i was shouting
oh my god oh my god did you used to be
like a
race car driver wait this is a different
car than i thought it was
also what is the haunting whooshing
there is some deep scary lord of this
game and i don't know what it is
let's just sweep her let's give her a
nice wash down first
you might find the streaky line where
bird tried to clean it with his power
washer
dribble washer more like it
[Laughter]
listen many people feel inadequate to
the mighty
gush of my power washer it is
quite profound in its blastitude
lexian please make bleep everything i
just said
just bleep out this whole episode
well [ __ ] me [ __ ] me right now me
me right now no about that by jiminy
that's right
i used to race this beast all over it's
gotta grunt like an angry rhino
heck i won the 1989 race of the
champions in it
race of the champions turbo faster no
no i didn't i watched it on tv all right
whatever
whatever man just i'm gonna clean your
car and you're gonna
you're gonna tell me more stories about
your past
man this new this this like deluxe
washer is almost too powerful it makes
things really easy
because i'm i'm on the white one like
the widest nozzle and is still just like
blasting a lot of these stains i mean
the rust and the stuff yeah that needs
some
more intense treatment but just to get
like the bulk of it
i'm already 33 done and this isn't like
too cheap of a job
uh not the cheapest job in the world
some of the rust though that's going to
need the
the turbo blaster hey dirt
yeah what
what get lost would you okay
i'm gonna ignore that because i don't
want to keep shouting in this episode
power washing simulator is not a
not a game to be shouting in
lexington just make it like text to
speech but make it like very loud
text-to-speech if that sounds bad don't
put it in
but if it's in any way funny put it in
ha ha ha
i just imagined the robo voice shouting
at the toughest lung
anyway don't put in my react i don't
know do whatever you want lexie and i
i'm
i'm not the boss of you
[Music]
i'm actually gonna this is this is weird
but i'm gonna do a mouse swap
because i have my my little wireless
mouse here but uh it really doesn't get
the kind of precision like i like this
mouse but it's
it's just a wireless uh like imprecise
not gaming mouse
i'm i have another mouse i'm going to do
a
i'm going to do a swap this needs some
extra love and precision
i finally feel like a pro gamer guys i'm
doing a i'm doing a swap
need top level performance to really
enhance my power washing
i need to really be a pro gamer pro
gamer
i play games for a living it makes me
profound
oh that's much better oh the precision
all the precision
oh the precision oh my god the precision
let's see if i can get away with this i
don't know if this can kill russ can
this kill rust
that kinda
[Music]
if this hits this thing just turn on
is grandpa miller in the car
how long will you be i was thinking uh
lexie and you got this how long will you
be i was thinking of taking the car for
a tear up down the old abandoned sewer
system
[Music]
i think for the rust just you gotta
turbo it like there's no other way to do
it
it just needs that kind of like power
blasting
and once you get it it's pretty easy to
do that at least you only take one pass
i've had a word with lenny and he's
certainly not going to be tearing it up
down the sewer system we'll be sticking
to main street for now i don't know he
could tear up the
sewer system if he wants i think that'd
be pretty dope
be pretty dope to me anyway the oh my
god
i sincerely thought that that was
someone standing in the street that
scared the crap out of me
oh not expecting it in this game but i'm
kind of also a little bit expecting
there to be a little bit of a horror
twist to this game
it would be the perfect thing i would be
completely unsuspecting
totally relaxed you know all kinds of
like oh it's so
satisfying and yet uh oh something's not
right there goes my spleen
can i just say like uh seeing the
response to me playing this game has
been
pretty lovely i mean i thought i was
crazy
in how much i love the game like i
really did like i thought that i was
nuts i thought that something must be
wrong with me like why would i
play this game four episodes for four
hours i thought it was gonna be like the
biggest waste of time like no one was
gonna watch it
yet like i'm not crazy like there's
something
here there's something about this game
there's something about this
the way the water splashes and the way
the dirt just disappears and the way the
shine
starts to take over on the car like it
really starts to come to life
once you get into the cracks and
crevices and you kind of restore
something that was like
previously kind of beat down but then
like oh and when it does come together
it's just
and i mean the development team has been
so nice too because they've been like
commenting that like they can't believe
that i've been playing the game
too and i'm like i can't believe that
i'm playing the game either but
it's good it's good it's good also ethan
told me that he's he sent me like a
a code for this game a long time ago and
he was like hey you probably like this
game and i
you know like all of his messages i
ignored it so
i mean i think i just it was like i put
it on the back burner i was like yeah
i'll get to it when i get to it like
maybe maybe it'll happen maybe i won't
who knows i was busy probably going to
canada or something
with all my incredible projects that i'm
working on okay what am i what am i
missing i don't even know anymore
i don't have the uh to-do list so i'm
guessing that i have more than just a
few
okay spoiler what about the spoiler
aha okay car
windscreen wing mirror okay got it
in the nook okay wing mirror
[Music]
okay and then it just says car
i don't know what that means i'm not a
hundred percent sure oh
god i see what that means what the hell
and that is pretty good and i think in
three
two one done doc the car looks so fresh
you are so a pastor haha i cannot wait
to see old bert's face
when me and dolores streak past his
front yard and he sees what a power
washing pro can do
yeah suck it burt and your weak power
washing skills
oh yeah there we go
[Music]
that's nice
[Music]
i feel like i've got a pretty good
strategy when i do this like i do i go
over the whole thing i get the small
details and then i start to blast the
bigger
but more persistent stains i don't think
there's anything new to buy by the way
i think it's just ah man i can't wait
for a professional duty washer
like i don't know if they're gonna have
a whole line of washers with all these
kind of different things that you gotta
use for different stains and
that'd be cool and all but i just kind
of like i don't know maybe i want a
professional duty one maybe i'm fine
with the one i got because it's really
not about like the
speed of the wash it's just like doing
whatever you do oh
interesting yeah so they changed it up
how soap works
i don't know soaps are stupid anyone
that has soaps doesn't really respect
the craft
and i respect the craft what do we have
here
what do we have here all right well
that's dirty all right i'm going to say
this right now
oh my god someone watched someone trying
to get in or someone trying to get out
lots of little knickknacks this a 300
buck
job yeah i guess if i did the whole
building for however many dollars i did
all right well i guess we could just
start with the front you know
i'm not gonna do the whole wrap around
like i've done before
just gonna focus on like the details of
it because i mean this is a big
thing so if i don't get everything on
the front first
i don't think i'm gonna notice it
[Music]
oh yeah that is a lot of baked in rust
that is some
caked on rust this actually might call
for uh
soap like i'm not gonna lie this job
might need some soap especially for
stuff like that that is so
obviously baked in there like i know i
said soap was stupid but
i like i i don't intend to use soap as
like a blanket sweep
get everything done quick as possible i
think
it's it's best purpose is obviously for
uh stains that
need the like this look it's just like
super blasted so it's
probably better for using it on like
yeah this stuff needs
can i get more reload reload oh i gotta
buy
beforehand that makes sense i have to
buy it beforehand
well looks like i'm not doing any uh any
of that
i mean that's good that makes sense
that's controlling me a little bit you
have to pre-plan your buys
it kind of like puts a thing where you
okay i gotta make sure i got everything
i need for the job before i go out for
the job
unless i can just go to the
[Music]
interesting well i might as well stock
up i got nothing else to buy
okay i went to the store and i'm back
man that was tough
oh that's nice it just puts all the soap
uh
in the the place with the
thing yeah see this stuff is stubborn
well that stuff is stubborn in there
[Music]
yeah my god that's in there get that
grill
done
[Music]
how's this bumper not done yet am i
missing something on the bumper
you part of the bumper no
there we go okay and that is a clean
front
oh no it's not
okay and that is a clean front that no
other is not
okay and okay that is a clean front
that looks good
and it really looks bad by contrast that
is just
but we can continue on with just like
the normal washers for now i think
unless something's like super super
super ingrained
with like rust rust is really the
biggest [ __ ]
and i think like i can just imagine that
the soap is some specialized
rust killer because otherwise it is just
uh it's just gonna be caked in there
except for like this hubcap like clearly
i can i could blast this individually
i said clearly i can blast this
individually i
said clearly i can blast
this individually
[Music]
clearly i can blast this individually
i swear to god what is wrong with you i
said clearly
i can blast this
my god what's wrong with this thing
oh thank you thank you for that
god the rotated version is so much more
useful than like
any other orientation how did i do this
flat for so long
how did i do it i don't know
[Music]
i'll tell you what this truck is abute
underneath this grime
and i guess like it's understandable
it's kind of driving into fires
so this doesn't make sense i should have
left the handprint
there's a theory that the cat's not
really missing
what do you mean what do you mean
that the mayor's using it as a
distraction device so no one notices all
that pipeline stuff
what do you mean what do you mean
pipeline stuff what are you talking
about is this the dark dirty underbelly
of the
pow-wow simulator law the law that i've
been craving
that i'm sure matpat has been concocting
at this
very moment
unmistakable
all right wheel you're gonna be a
[Music]
bastard
there we go now that's more like it oh
this side is grimy
oh this side is grimy it's got rusted
i'm gonna hit this part with the soap
definitely because this is just oh this
is crusty
yeah let's just go ahead and soap it up
all right let's see if we can finish off
these
[Music]
there we go that's looking pretty good
okay that's good enough for now oh tire
are you not done
how are you not done there we go okay so
that
is the front half of the truck looking
pretty good except for probably the top
so let's get that good what does that
say
police police fired
police rules fire drills
disagree on that
okay and that is the front cabin very
nice oh look it's beautiful
it is something special now to get the
rest of this
um lots of little knock knacks i might
as well just blast it
just because there's so many little
knick-knacks
hey do you know if the mayor's cat still
is missing i'm up at the volcano and i
think i can see him on the outer rim
i'm going for a closer look
if i hear a big explosion from the
volcano nearby i'm gonna assume that
that did not go very well
oh it counts it as one big thing the
control panel is like one unit oh
interesting
my stupid i'm not seeing any more dirt
that might be stupid and go the other
[Music]
side
[Music]
yeah i would have done the this with the
other side from the get-go if i had
known it wasn't just a lot of individual
parts
because that is the problem with the
soap is like if you use it like a
shotgun blast it's really not going to
do what you want it to do
you really just got to use it on like
the super stubborn stains
that are over big large areas because it
would just be
the best tool for the job at that point
it would be worth the money
just because of the time investment
alone but let's see if this actually
cleans all this or if there's something
still missing to it
which it seems like there is wow
how stubborn are you gonna be answer is
apparently very stubborn you [ __ ]
get clean
oh it got clean interesting yeah i think
the problem is like
these are actually nooks and these are
crannies so i can't
see to the bottom of them
i knew it i knew it
i knew it you way whole that's where
things get easier
look at this look at this barely any
fire touched this one
we have a lovely little job for you up
at the house when you're free
aura smith and jenny pebbles okay
weird names but i'm not gonna question
it's definitely ulysses i can see his
funny leg
don't go in the volcano buddy why would
a cat hang out ten feet from a lava flow
though yeah
maybe it's not a cat maybe it's a demon
you ever think about that you ever think
that maybe it might not be a cat and
actually it is one heck of a
demon you ever think maybe demon world's
best log fire
i don't know if cats like log fires i'm
pretty sure i've never
pulled cats before on their preferences
of fires but i don't think log rank's
very high
um and i don't think that you should
theorize much about a
cat's preference of heat 10 feet from a
volcano
and vinsmir
ding ding ding
[Music]
okay and that is the back for the most
part
and then one more side and then we get
the top and then we're pretty much done
with this
not much left to go it's been a pretty
fun one there's like some challenging
bits to it
uh like with the handles and whatnot but
like nothing a procedural blast with the
turbo filter could do once again proving
that soap is for
losers and fools and every time i try to
justify
soap's existence i remember that the
developers wanted to make it easy for
some people
but in in doing so it's a trap uh
because they wanted people that wanted
the easy way out to get stuck with a
perpetual cycle of buying soap and
feeling inadequate about themselves
which is exactly how i don't feel i feel
incredible about myself because my skill
is incredible and i'm not going to
remember that i
forgot how to rotate the nozzle for
about four episodes i played this game
for 11 hours
before i learned that i could rotate the
nozzle
that's probably not good that's probably
a bad track record
i'm going to say that straight up i'm an
idiot
no idiocy that i've ever done is
probably intentional
i wish it was all right actually i'm
going to leave this letter over there
because i don't want it getting in the
way of my cleanliness
[Music]
boy howdy that's spotty ah this is
actually where soap would come in handy
i'm doing the thing that i said only
idiots would do
la la la la la la la la la la la la la
however this is kind of exactly what i
prescribed when i was trying to justify
soap's existence
large areas of probably particularly
difficult things to clean
like rust okay is it done nope
see it's so spotty it's so spotty
[Music]
listen uh developers of this game unless
you make the
soap a bit more uh engaging in terms of
its mechanics
i don't see it actually being any better
than just straight up washing
who uses soap anyway take it out of the
game take it out don't even let it be an
option
hey there we go tie yours tires
damn
[Music]
okay and handles there must be some more
handles that i've missed
[Music]
and that one's okay handle
bladder fa you're a legend that was
absolutely pristine even the rust's gone
that should get the mayor off our backs
for a while which means we can all get
back to doing the jobs we're paid for
thanks pal oh yeah
there she blows oh that's a good one
that's a good one that's a good one
that's a nice one right there oh that's
a nice one i did pretty good on that one
i did pretty good i did pretty good i am
not too upset about that one
oh wreck vehicle i think that one might
be one of the new ones in terms of
uh the latest update uh but hey thank
you guys so much for watching and thank
you for enjoying this series i really do
appreciate you guys
uh sticking around with me for it and i
know i've said it a lot but check out
distractable if you haven't
the only reason i say it so much is
because i'm having so much fun with bob
and wade
making the uh podcast it's really just
an excuse for us to have fun and i think
you guys will honestly enjoy it it's a
lot of laughs like those guys make me
laugh so damn hard every week
so every monday we put out a new podcast
so go check it out links in the
description thank you everybody so much
for watching
i'm going to be off filming the sequel
to heist so thank you
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you